el break city sigue complicando las
cosas en irlanda del norte el jueves el
ministro principal porque iván renunció
a su cargo luego de las amenazas de su
partido de colapsar el gobierno
descentralizado en protesta por el
protocolo de irlanda del norte
es el principio del consentimiento es
una piedra angular del acuerdo de
belfast y deseo sinceramente que todos
los sectores de la comunidad pronto
puedan dar su consentimiento para la
restauración de un ejecutivo en pleno
funcionamiento a través de la resolución
de los problemas que lamentablemente nos
han llevado a este punto del play pro
dos sets point la renuncia de gilvan
provoca la dimisión de lápiz entre el
ministro del sinn fein kutcher o'neal
quien debe renunciar debido al acuerdo
de poder compartido de irlanda del norte
lo que suma al gobierno una vez más en
la incertidumbre sin que puedan tomar
decisiones importantes su renuncia sigue
la decisión del ministro de agricultura
de ordenar la suspensión de los
controles de productos agrícolas del
resto del reino unido ahora ha emitido
una instrucción formal a mi secretario
permanente para que detenga todos los
controles que no estaban en su lugar el
31 de diciembre de 2020 a partir de la
medianoche de hoy prepare un documento
para la consideración ejecutiva en un
futuro cercano para buscar un acuerdo
sobre una manera adelante 1b de favor el
protocolo implementado en 2021 permite
la libre circulación de mercancías que
cruzan la frontera de irlanda del norte
a la república de irlanda y mantiene
irlanda del norte en la unión aduanera
de la unión europea pero impone
controles a los bienes que ingresan e
irlanda del norte desde gran bretaña
creando así una frontera en el marte
irlanda los políticos unionistas se
oponen enérgicamente a los controles
porque significan que irlanda del norte
recibe un trato diferente al de
inglaterra gales y escocia
los controles aún no se han detenido y
westminister dijo que estaba revisando
la situación un portavoz de la comisión
europea dijo que el protocolo era la
única solución para salvaguardar el
acuerdo de viernes santo de 1998 que
puso fin a 30 años de violencia entre la
república de irlanda y gran bretaña
[Aplausos]